welcome this is the end of our second
week here at largo theater and it's
really nice wonderful to be out of the
house and working in a safe open
environment let me tell you something
very quickly about the largo theater
there's a lot of strange stuff in here
it's a very popular comedy theater all
the great comics perform here and
there's lots of weird mementos backstage
and i've spent a lot of time here and i
keep seeing this it's a pillow a pillow
that's crocheted to look like i don't
know if you can see this sarah silverman
and this is something i look at a
hundred times a day while I'm here at
the theatre and I have to say I know
Sarah well lover she's fantastic very
beautiful woman
this pillow doesn't really do her
justice I don't think this is an
accurate representation of Sarah
Silverman and so what I'm going to do
before I leave this theater when it's
time for us to move on is I'm gonna have
I swear a better more beautiful less
dirty and musty Sarah Silverman pillow
made and that's my promise to America